bonsoir florian philippot merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors vous avez
écrit ce livre pour dit vous ne plus
vivre cela le fiasco européen sur la
santé les mensonges du gouvernement le
scandale des ehpad où la sphère de
l'hydroxyde leur quine laquelle le sang
selon vous doit-on en tirer mais je
crois qu'on peut déjà en tirer les
leçons mais malheureusement mais encore
on vit encore en absurdie si vous voulez
on doit on a bien vu tous les français
ont vu les mensonges du début de
l'épidémie quand canton en france on a
été un des seuls pays à ne pas fermer
nos frontières par exemple ce qui est
hallucinant et en fait on ne l'a jamais
fait pendant la crise
c'est incompréhensible on a on est tout
de suite tombé sur raul quand il a
proposé un traitement
on a on a dit d'abord que les masses ne
servait à rien j'en avais pas pour les
soignants ce qui est un véritable
scandale et maintenant on nous dit
exactement inverse
il faut en mettre partout pour tout le
monde obligatoire que c'est la panacée
mais on nous parle même plus de ce qui
est l'essentiel c'est-à-dire d'abord se
laver les mains
il ya il ya quelque chose qui cloche
dans cette affaire depuis le début ça a
été très mal gérée l'union européenne
effectivement un rôle délétère pascal
ouvrant nos frontières a détruit notre
système de santé par l'austérité
désindustrialise grandement la france et
on l'a payé très cher
nommé si rien n'est réglé et pour le
moment on s'enfonce en absurdie par des
décisions de plus en plus déconnectés de
la réalité sanitaire et qui moi me font
peur je ne sais pas dans quelle société
on nous prépare demain en tout cas je
pense qu'on n'aura pas plus de sécurité
sanitaire et surtout va y perdre en
terme de liberté et de prospérité
alors vous dressez évidemment le constat
de tous les dysfonctionnements qu'il y a
eu pendant pendant le confinement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous trouvez que le
gouvernement en a tiré les conséquences
on voit la politique des tests qui est
quand même un peu hasardeuse
une politique de confinement par
quartier une politique en tout cas à
géométrie variable les français sont un
peu perdus aujourd'hui qu'en pensez vous
ah mais je pense qu'on continue dans le
grand cirque si vous voulez la politique
de test est très symptomatique vous avez
raison d'abord il n'y a pas de tests
quand il fallait qu'il en est en mars
avril et quasiment pas de fesses alors
qu'il fallait
non mais beaucoup il y avait à l'époque
huit cent mille morts par jour je le
rappelle un maintenant c'est profusion
de tests tous remboursés d'ailleurs par
la sécurité sociale moi je pense qu'au
bout plus ciblées il faut cibler pour
avoir des résultats en moins de 24
heures est idéalement même en moins de
12 heures mais en ciblant et en
remboursant uniquement ceux qui auront
une prescription médicale
ce qui permettra d'alléger soul et les
files d'attenté puis ça rendra plus
efficace beaucoup plus efficace les
choses
c'est incroyable cette affaire là c'est
si comme des masques et ils veulent un
peu exorciser on dirait leur péché
originel il n'y avait pas de masquer pas
de test alors aujourd'hui nous met des
tests et des masques partout franchement
le manifestement c'est que ça fonctionne
pas c'est pas la bonne solution
au final on ferait mieux de regarder par
exemple les suédois et se doit la veille
un épidémiologiste très compétent qui
s'appelle anders terminale et qui dit il
faut faire autrement
nous on croit pas aux masses obligatoire
à l'extérieur on pense qu'il ya même un
risque de contamination si vous
l'utilisez mal si vous utilisez pour le
même masque quand le contaminant parce
que vous avez mis vos mains partout et
que vous savez pas comment le bien le
maître vous ne changez pas toutes les
trois heures comme il faut et et eux en
suède depuis fin juin ils ont des
résultats bien meilleurs chez nous on va
plus en plus à la restriction des
libertés la restriction de la vie
culturelle 0 manière en tout cas de
marie france ne rapprochent de ceux de
la france qui sont pas forcément bien
meilleure mais en tout cas ils sont
quasiment similaires
c'est à dire qu'au global et finissent
par être similaire à ce qu'au début ils
ont un excès de mortalité importante
dans les ehpad ils ont mal géré faut le
dire les quinze premiers jours très mal
gérée dans leur maison de retraite à
prison corriger mais depuis fin juin ils
sont très largement devant nous et
surtout ils détruisent beaucoup moins
leur vie économique leur vie sociale
leur vie scolaire leur vie culturelle
leur vie démocratique en france
je sais pas quel monde on ne prépare
mais il n'est pas il n'est pas joyeux et
et surtout il et on va vers des
restrictions considérables de nos
libertés ni remise en cause
incroyable jamais vu de l'état de droit
et cela devrait faire débat or ça ne
fait pas débat il ya une espèce de
consensus parmi les autorités en tout
cas qui moi m'interpelle et me fait peur
parlons des chiffres qui sont donnés
tous les soirs chez une sur rt france
également de façon très factuelle 26
morts hier 12
aujourd'hui on peut pas parler d'une
deuxième vague
concrètement non bien sûr que non mais
vous avez beaucoup de médecins en
épidémiologie ce qu'ils disent depuis le
début on peut pas parler d'une deuxième
vague et parce qu'on n'est pas du tout
au niveau
dieu merci de ce qu'on a connu pendant
le printemps et mêmes vous voyez vous
citer les chiffres ça fait trois jours
d'affilée qui a une forte baisse du
solde de d'hospitalisation tang le ton
mieux mais donc ça veut dire qu'on n'est
pas dans la même situation salutaire il
faut toujours faire attention moi je
crois qu'on doit contrôler nos
frontières et nos aéroports
on doit bien se laver les mains on doit
faire attention aux personnes fragiles
c'est une évidence deux et qu'on doit
travailler sur un traitement mais je
trouve qu'on a mis de côté raout et
d'autres de manière incroyable et rapide
alors ne peut sûrement parce qu'il
propose un traitement pas cher et que là
aussi c'est un des sujets que je traite
dans livre celui des conflits d'intérêts
qui à mon avis est un sujet extrêmement
important
mais cette fois je pense qu'il faut
faire ça il faut faire attention mais on
peut on doit arrêter d'affoler la
population et je regarde qui est pas
beaucoup de partis politiques pour pour
pour le dire c'est notre rôle de le dire
et de proposer d'autre stratégie que de
détruire la france
alors si personne ne s'en indigner
véritablement est ce que c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup d'informations
non plus sur sur ce virus qui est quand
même assez assez opaques non
effectivement il est nouveau donc
alors en même temps il ya une recherche
mondiale qui est plus forte que sur
aucun autre virus dans l'histoire et ça
se comprend
donc je pense qu'on apprend très très
vite je sais que les réanimateurs ont
fait d'immenses progrès et c'est
vraiment très heureux il sauve des vies
ils ont sauvé des vies
par rapport au début de l'épidémie je
pense que l'on apprend quand même
beaucoup mais on tâtonne forcément parce
qu il malgré tout il a moins d'un an ce
virus donc donc ça reste assez récent
mais au-delà de ça il ya quand même des
choses justes bons sens pas juge de bon
sens
comment se fait-il que l'on ferme pas
nous avons pas eu nos frontières
véritablement qu'on fasse pas de vrais
de vrais contrôles vis-à-vis des pays
vraiment un risque aujourd'hui parce
qu'on sait que les dynamiques de
d'épidémie sont pas les mêmes dans le
monde
même moment pourquoi dans le même temps
on par exemple à nice là on a interdit
la vente d'alcool après 20 heures
quel lien à stimuler que la situation
sanitaire l'histoire des masques quand
vous êtes en moto mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce voyage en absurdie ouais
c'est voit d'un côté à des mesures
évidentes comprend encore parler des
tests aussi d'autres côtés ont fondé
mesure absurde qui sont destructrices
par exemple on ferme une classe en
entier parce que les lèvres un rhume on
peut pas affirmer comme ça une classe
d'un coup une école ça n'a pas de sens
et c'est grave c'est gravissime
c'est un acte les lourds de fermer une
classe où une école pour l'instruction
d'un enfant d'une classe et pour le
niveau général d'éducation du pays alors
on renouera votre livre vous dites que
notre appartenance à l'union européenne
est souvent l'angle mort de l'analyse
des politiques de l'opposition pourquoi
parce que moi je vais beaucoup de monde
dans l'est notamment parmi les
politiques les responsables syndicaux
ils compris dans l'opposition s'indigne
et à juste titre que l'on avait appauvri
l'hôpital qui ont manqué de beaucoup de
choses que la france avait délocalisé
énormément d'industrie est indispensable
y compris dans cette crise par exemple
le ballet vous savez les réactifs pour
les têtes les cotons-tiges il manque etc
bah oui enfin d'accord mais cela reste
qualité des gouvernements mais c'est
aussi parce qu'on appartient à l'union
européenne et c'est surtout parce qu'on
appartient à l'union européenne voilà
c'est fait c'est un concours de
pleurnicheurs alors là elle l'a tout
récemment sa pas le dire que coville ils
sont allé pleurnicher sur bridgestone
qui faire qui va délocaliser en pologne
et en hongrie mais tout ça c'est lié à
notre appartenance à l'union européenne
à long et ça il n'en parle jamais si
vous voulez qui déplore les conséquences
des causes qu'ils chérissent comme
disait bossuet c'est à dire les adore
l'union européenne et puis il pleure sur
les conséquences de l'union européenne
un peu de rigueur et un peu de cohérence
maintenant et moi j'en appelle à cette
cohérence par le fait qu site
c'est-à-dire est assorti de l'union
européenne et de l'euro le plus vite
possible vous critiquez l'ailé
d'ailleurs les injonctions l'union
européenne sur la santé qui a produit en
tout cas la destruction des de l'hôpital
public on l'a vu pendant pendant le
confinement aujourd'hui vous pensez que
les leçons seront pas tiré le plan blanc
d'ailleurs qui a été déclenché dans les
hôpitaux vous pensez qu'on
on est au même point qu'au début de
l'épidémie avait coûté tant qu'on est de
ceux là sont dans l'union européenne il
faut pas s'attendre à autre chose qu'une
destruction accélérée notre service
public
vous savez là à la rentrée ils vont
encore fermé des lits à strasbourg des
lits de réanimation
1 les gens ont peut-être vont apprendre
ça ils vont en croit rêver il ya pas du
tout que cette ville qui est concerné en
france il ya des fermetures de lits qui
sont programmés là pour la rentrée 1
donc si oui tant qu'on est dans cette
logique de la profitabilité de la t2a
soul et la tarification à l'activité
alors tout ça c'est lié à la vision
bruxelloise européenne du service public
qui doit devenir un service marchand a
tant qu'on continue là dedans avec des
gouvernements soumis à cette idéologie
là et bien il faut pas s'attendre à ce
qu'on change de philosophie faut pas
s'attendre à ce que ça aille mieux
très cool moi vraiment qu'on appelle
être extrêmement cohérent c'est un des
enjeux aussi pieux livre effectivement
très court florian philippot dans le
dernier chapitre de votre livre vous
appeler à la révolte à se révolter en
tout cas à l'intelligence collective
expliquez vous oui j'en si vous voulez
on voit bien c'est la marraine je cite
un arène dans le livre en disant on
arrête a expliqué que pour qu'un peuple
ne soit docile et n'y comprennent plus
rien et qui deviennent obéissent en
quelque sorte sans trop réfléchir
il faut lui donner les injonctions
contradictoires en permanence désolé on
lui dit abbas qui est bien aujourd'hui
c'est blanc puis demain à valence et
noir aujourd'hui
euh voilà bon alors et puis le peuple
gouvernement il comprend plus rien eh
bien c'est exactement ce qu'on le régime
auquel on nous contraint depuis
plusieurs mois on nous a dit les masses
à rien puis c'est indispensable et est
pareil et puis et puis voilà tu on n'y
comprend plus rien et c'est le meilleur
moyen pour qu'on devienne dociles et
obéissants
il faut ce qu'il faut se rebeller par
rapport à ça il faut garder son esprit
critique
il faut garder un esprit logique il faut
mettre il faut garder un esprit sur le
temps long de mettre en perspective les
paroles et les événements et et se
forcer à comprendre et à rester
intelligent c'est la première révolte
cette révolte de l'intelligence elle
entraînera les autres la révolte pour la
liberté et la révolution politique que
j'appelle c'est à dire un programme de
salut public pour la renaissance de la
france merci beaucoup florian philippot
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
sur arte france
je rappelle le titre de votre livre
comme il dit
neuf l'oligarchie est démasqué publié
sur amazon